so a lot of people come out here with
dreams and I'm not saying anything wrong
with dreaming but have some kind of
strategic plan that you mean when I was
coming here black man big guy dark there
was no internet there was no YouTube
Facebook people to look at like me right
now coming out here then create
webisodes for nothing and make him be
seen the network can be seen and they
can actually like what It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia start off as a webisode
Danny DeVito saw it and that was not
nine years so the thing is is that I
mean I always say to these kids what are
you waiting for you waiting for a system
that is I think what is I forgot the
exact stats it's AG but I think it's
that at the entire Union between five
and ten percent work at all annually
that that 10% only a couple of a
percentages make over ten thousand
dollars a year just go by the stats so
if you don't come in here understanding
the reality what you're facing
it's not the most pleasant journey so
knowing that people do change coming out
here and I've witnessed it myself and
just casual just knowing certain people
over the years and it does it does
change you how can someone preserve
themselves a little bit or be maybe not
as jaded or maybe they go through a
jaded period and then they come out the
other side do you have any
recommendations was there ever a time
when you wanted to just quit the
business I know you had gone through a
time in the 80s when you felt your
overexposed or maybe an agent told you
that
so it sounds like everybody almost has
to have this like rollercoaster ride a
little bit is there a way to flatline or
no that doesn't happen there's a great
book there's two books that I would
recommend to people one is by Steven
Pressfield it's called the war of art
it's one of the greatest books I've ever
read helped change my life the war of
art another one is by Seth Godin it's
called the dip in the dip talks about
people who are serious about whatever
they're doing they go go go then they
have a dip you know and they have one of
two choices of getting out of that you
know you can continue doing what you're
doing or you can begin to learn from
where you've been and turn it into an
advantage so if you want to be an
actress for 20 years or 15 years and you
never really were able to get foot a
foothold or a great agent or whatever
you can either stop or you can say hmm
how can I use another way of getting to
where I want to go and today there's no
excuse I said webisodes Mobile TV games
cell phone apps kids made a feature film
with two cell phones I mean what are you
waiting for the thing is that we were
caught in this old paradigm that I
cannot do anything without the
permission of a system and if you
continue to think of it that way you're
right you're waiting for permission but
suppose you say I'm no longer waiting
for permission I'm going to create my
own opportunity and then be perfect in
the beginning but I'm going to refine it
I'm going to create strategic alliances
I'm an actor writer
but I know a starve a starving director
over there that guy isn't worked in five
years and he's looking for something
maybe he and I well I know a set
designer who's kind of horror producer
hasn't was fired four years ago hasn't
worked sentencing but that kind of
thinking it's in the book that Seth
Godin wrote called tribes he says stop
trying to do it by yourself stop trying
to do it by yourself you don't have to
you